we are talking sweet treats with this
week with our friends at las vegas
weekly i got to sit down with them this
week with more on how to cool off as the
weather
scorches on all right well today we are
talking with cindy reed from las vegas
weekly thank you so much for joining us
here today
uh and i know what that uh with the
temperature
obviously it's going up here in the
valley summertime is just around the
corner what better way
to embrace this heat than with some
summer treats right
exactly it is hot hot hot outside and
only getting hotter
so um i think a little ice cream
shaved ice is always a wonderful
way to just relax wind down and cool off
all right so we have a list here of
different spots that
you guys found across the valley that
are some of your favorites
paradise city creamery is a huge
standout
downtown in the arts district it's
gluten-free it's plant-based and yet
it's oh so sinful if you read the names
of the ice creams which we actually
can't say here but the company was
created by
a veteran sex worker and community
organizer
we have two different shaved ice
locations in
our um in
in the book and so that is a purple
penguin which you can find around town
as well as
a sit-down place in chinatown that is
called sewell and beans
is there anything somewhat healthy for
us on that list
so for a healthy choice you could go
with lealana's bananas which is just
really fun to say if nothing else but
you get frozen bananas and then it's
your choice
of dipping different toppings in it you
can dip it in chocolate you can dip it
in nuts i would recommend
mora ice cream in summerland they make
ice cream the old fashioned way
where it's in small batches and
we definitely recommend the waffle cone
bowl
filled with a variety of seasonal scoops
the most fun waffle cone
is the actual waffle cone that's shaped
like a giant fish with an open mouth
all right thank you so much cindy reed
with las vegas weekly thank you so much
we'll be talking to you soon
thank you all right well the newest
edition of las vegas weekly is out now
and guys i have to tell you a little
secret of mine the best time for me to
eat ice cream is when it's really cold
or when it's raining outside i don't
know why i just crave it
wow that is interesting christian you're
probably the only person on earth that's
awesome so what's your favorite uh
type kind of ice cream thank you guys
turkey hill good gelato the quality kind
yes yes yes um there's one you guys i
want to tell you about it's a unicorn
ice cream i did it on a live shot yes
you did it on the first friday
yeah it's a first friday i'm gonna get
your name on social media because she's
awesome and it is
and we got them for harlow's birthday we
put them in the freezer
and literally a month later they were
still that good
not kidding wow i'll let you guys know
about social media and the purple
penguins i didn't know about them until
we got here to las vegas
yeah those stands get quite popular next
time we get some rain
christian and i we're going to get some
ice cream i guess so
oddball